et avec nous pour ce club Paul casser
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
professeurs de droit public à
l'Université Paris Panthéon Sorbonne et
Bruno Cauterets bonjour
brunochère
Audrey évidemment nous a rejoint on va
reparler de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel qui a donc décidé pour
la deuxième fois de rejeter la demande
de référendum déposé par les
parlementaires de gauche coup dur pour
les opposants mais la bataille est-elle
désormais perdue vous nous le direz ou
les députés peuvent-ils le 8 juin voter
l'abrogation du texte on en parle dans
quelques instants avec vous et puis
après les violences du 1er mai le
gouvernement réfléchit une loi
anti-casseurs pour éviter que les
casseurs viennent tuer du flic ce sont
les mots des rides Dupont-Moretti mais
quelle est la marge de manœuvre
juridique jusqu'où peut aller le
gouvernement sans risquer la censure du
Conseil constitutionnel on en parle dans
quelques instants d'abord on regarde
l'actualité dans nos régions
[Musique]
et l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale et
des télévisions locales on va à Tours on
retrouve Michael Texier bonjour Michael
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
rédacteur en chef à Tv Tours Michael
vous allez nous parler SOS Racisme qui
porte plainte contre le président de la
métropole pour un jour à caractère
racial expliquait non et oui on a
l'habitude de parler de tout métropole
ici sur le territoire mais pas
uniquement évidemment parce que
l'institution politique est l'une des
plus puissantes du département dernière
affaire en date vous venez de l'évoquer
le président Frédéric oGIS classé à
droite est accusé par Cédric des
Oliveira l'un de ses vices présidents
d'un jour raciste ce dernier détail
l'effet présumé dans une lettre adressée
à frédéric-augis et au préfet
d'Indre-et-Loire nous sommes le 4 avril
la session budgétaire de la métropole
vient de se terminer le cocktail qui
suit est sur sa faim à ce moment les
deux hommes ont une discussion agitée
qui dérape Frédéric oGIS reproche à
Cédric des Oliveira son manque
d'empressement à participer à des
réunions politiques de la majorité à
laquelle il appartient il l'aurait
traité alors un petit vice-président et
dans la foulée de salle portugais autour
d'eux quelques élus de la métropole dans
son courrier Cédric de Oliveira dénonce
je cite des propos racistes profondément
offensant il reproche par ailleurs je
cite toujours l'emportement et la
brutalité du président et menace de
porter plainte si ses propos devaient
être réitérer pendant quelques jours
l'information prend alors la forme d'une
rumeur dans les rédaction et c'est nos
confrères de France 3 qui évoquent
l'affaire les premiers du côté des deux
concernés silence radio depuis plusieurs
semaines
frédéric-augis s'est excusé par lettre
auprès de Cédric de Oliveira c'est ce
que révèle le confrères du site internet
local 37 degrés mais le mal est fait
dénonce la communauté portugaise
nombreuse entourées et notamment dans la
ville de Joué-lès-Tours dont le maire et
Frédéric cogis une affaire qui résonne
jusqu'au Portugal même porté par le
député PS des Portugais d'Europe
apparaissent par ailleurs deux anciennes
plaintes déposées en 2011 et 2014 par un
militant socialiste d'origine portugaise
pour violence volontaire et propos
xénophobe de plainte classée sans suite
de plaintes ok les SOS Racisme fait
référence dans celles que l'association
vient de déposer auprès du tribunal
judiciaire de Paris pour un jour public
à caractère racial je vous propose
d'écouter chaque Diaby les membres du
bureau national de l'Association
qui que l'on soit nous sommes tous égaux
devant la loi il n'y a pas de raison
surtout d'autant plus de sur quoi venant
d'un élu de tenir des propos comme ça
comme je vous l'ai dit dans notre espace
public si on laisse passer ça veut dire
que tout est égal en banalisent et ben
nous n'acceptons pas ça en tant que
militant associatif c'est notre rôle
c'est de notre responsabilité de dire
que ces propos là et ben on doit les
condamner on ne doit pas les accepter on
doit pas les banaliser sinon on court à
la catastrophe
alors ce qui est motivé le dépôt de
plainte c'est le manque de réaction de
la préfecture et du parquet de Tours qui
aurait pu s'auto saisir de la faire une
enquête va être des légendée pour
déterminer la véracité des faits savoir
si l'injure si elle était avérée était
publique ou privée dans le premier cas
la peine maximale en couru et d'un an
d'emprisonnement et 45000 euros d'amende
dans le second 1500 euros d'amende la
métropole de Tours vous disait en
introduction on en parle souvent sur
notre territoire mais pas que pour des
bonnes raisons l'année dernière l'ancien
président avait été condamné en appel
pour avoir giflé son directeur de
cabinet il avait dû démissionner
merci beaucoup merci Michael Texier
d'avoir été avec nous rédacteur en chef
à TV tour pendant qu'on peut aller de
cette actualité du côté de tout on va
parler de la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel qui a donc rejeté pour
la deuxième fois la demande d'un
référendum sur la réforme des retraites
on va voir le détail et les réactions
politiques dans quelques instants mais
d'abord un mot Paul Cassia est-ce que
cette décision était surprenante est-ce
que ce rythme était mal écrit par les
parlementaires de gauche il était très
mal écrit et d'ailleurs ils l'ont dit
elles l'ont dit et c'était problématique
puisque il n'y a pas eu de défense du
Rip de la part de ces des personnes qui
l'ont soutenu au moment de son dépôt
donc le Conseil constitutionnel n'a pas
été invité par les parlementaires qui
ont déposé le rip à le valider c'est
quand même extraordinaire cette méthode
qui consiste à saisir le Conseil
constitutionnel et ensuite à ne pas
défendre coûte que coûte le texte qui a
été pourrait déposer c'est vrai que ce
texte a été déposé en dernière minute il
a été déposé la veille de la décision du
14 avril 2024 et donc sa rédaction elle
témoigne le rejet justifié d'ailleurs
puisqu'il a été rejeté le rejet du
premier RIB qu'ils avaient déposé
comment vous expliquer que deux rips
étaient mal écrit c'est quoi c'est une
erreur des parlementaires de gauche
alors je crois qu'il y a une
précipitation trop forte déjà le premier
RIP a été déposé tardivement il aurait
pu l'être déjà en vie ou février comme
ça d'ailleurs eu un peu de recul et puis
ensuite il y a une précipitation qui a
fait qu'on ils n'ont pas su elles n'ont
pas su comment rédiger le rip et cette
précipitation elle a été accrue par deux
éléments 1 premier élément le Conseil
constitutionnel a rendu une décision le
14 avril 2023 expliquant ce qu'est une
réforme et c'est la première fois qu'il
le disait explicitement et il a dit une
réforme c'est un changement de l'état du
droit donc il a fallu tenir compte de
cet élément nouveau et second élément
nouveau c'est que le président de la
République a promulgué aussitôt on s'en
souvient aussitôt la loi sur réformant
les retraites ce qui a coupé l'herbe sur
le pied des parlementaires de
l'opposition qui n'ont pas pu déposer
une troisième proposition de loi RIP qui
aurait tenu compte de la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel
on va voir justement les détails et puis
les réactions politiques à cette
décision du Conseil constitutionnel avec
Samia de chien
déçu mais pas résigné rassembler hier
soir dans plusieurs villes de France des
opposants à la réforme des retraites ont
appris le rejet d'une deuxième demande
de référendum par le Conseil
constitutionnel empêcher cette
consultation populaire qui aurait été
possible cette voilà c'était pour toi
une sortie de crise possible pour le
gouvernement qui est grandement
fragilisé mais l'autre senti de crise ce
serait de retirer la réforme de ne
jamais l'appliquer et comme ça a été
fait en 2006 à propos du CPE le Conseil
constitutionnel avait déjà rejeté le 14
avril une première demande de référendum
d'initiative partagée déposé par les
parlementaires de gauche pas vraiment
surpris par ce nouveau revers il dénonce
une procédure quasi inapplicable depuis
son entrée en vigueur en 2015 le rip
n'affranchit qu'une seule fois la
barrière du Conseil constitutionnel sur
la privatisation des aéroports de Paris
ce qu'on peut constater c'est que ce RIP
a peut-être été fait pour ne jamais
pouvoir être utilisé et que la cinquième
République a besoin d'être rénové et
d'avoir quelques conquêtes démocratiques
qui viennent revivifier une démocratie à
bout de souffle où les pouvoirs sont
excessifs pour l'exécutif et le
président de la République la droite
sénatoriale favorable à la réforme des
retraites estime au contraire que le
Conseil constitutionnel a rempli son
rôle de garant des institutions c'était
un secret de polichinelle que cette
deuxième formulation du Rip serait
retoquée par le Conseil constitutionnel
parce que l'été écrit par des militants
pas par des juristes et le Conseil
constitutionnel il juge en droit moi je
pense qu'il y a un dévoiement voyez du
Rip le rip a été fait pour faire la loi
faire la loi mais pas pour défaire la
loi tous les espoirs des opposants à la
réforme des retraites se tournent
désormais vers l'horizon du 8 juin
l'Assemblée nationale examinera une
proposition de loi des centristes du
groupe Liot pour abroger le report de
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite à 64
ans
Bruno c'est pas vraiment une surprise ce
rejet mais est-ce que c'est quand même
un coup dur pour les opposants
politiques à la réforme oui c'est un
coup dur parce que ça envoie
effectivement on vient d'en parler ça
envoie un message qui était qu'au fond
ça n'a pas été très bien préparé ça pas
été très bien rédigé c'est vrai aussi
que ça installe l'idée que comme on
disait une époque à propos du football
22 de type qui court après un ballon à
la fin c'est toujours l'Allemagne qui
gagne voilà ça donne un peu le sentiment
que c'est toujours Emmanuel Macron qui à
la fin est meilleur tacticien d'une
certaine manière c'est vrai qu'il a très
rapidement promulgué en coupant les sous
le pied d'une troisième proposition de
de RIP qui aurait pu être faite en
apprenant au fond des deux premiers
rejets et c'est vrai quand on lisait
l'argumentaire du Conseil
constitutionnel à l'issue du premier
rejet on avait l'impression que ça
donnait presque un mode d'emploi de
comment déposer un RIB et le deuxième
rythme ne semble pas avoir vraiment
compris en tout cas tenu compte de cet
argumentaire donc effectivement c'est un
coup dur pour les oppositions parce que
dans l'opinion publique si l'option
public pour le moment continue
de ne pas adhérer à la réforme
d'Emmanuel Macron à ses 64 ans on voit
que progressivement s'installe l'idée
que c'est fait que voilà qui on n'aime
pas cette réforme et qu'au fond
maintenant elle va rentrer en
application avec Emmanuel Macron est
arrivé à parvenu à ses fins on va en
parler sur la procédure du rythme alors
déjà est-ce que les opposants peuvent
redéposer un RIP dans un an il faut
attendre vraiment désormais il faut
attendre un an mais la décision du
conseil qui a été rendu hier en fait
interdit l'abrogation de la loi sur les
retraites qui portent les retraites à 64
ans il faut arrêter de se raconter des
histoires et de créer des fausses
espoirs il ne sera pas possible par la
voie du Rip d'abroger la loi qui porte à
64 ans là je départ la retraite pourquoi
parce que
si on repassait à 62 ans et bien ça
créerait des charges publiques et les
parlementaires ne peuvent pas c'est
l'articane de la Constitution
aggraver les charges publiques premier
point et second point ce que a dit le
Conseil constitutionnel hier il l'a
rappelé c'est que quand il y a une
disposition fiscale dans le rip il ne
passera pas parce qu'il faut que la
disposition soit sociale ou économique
donc il sera pas possible d'abroger via
le rip la loi du 14 avril 2023 qui porte
à 64 ans là je départ à la retraite
passons à autre chose sur le plan du Rip
trouvant si les parlementaires le
souhaitent une autre modalité de revenir
sur la loi du 14 avril 2023 un dernier
mot sur le riz parce que c'est quand
même une question qui est posée
notamment par les parlementaires de
gauche est-ce qu'il faut revoir la
procédure d'application de ce rythme
pardon je voudrais simplement dire que
la procédure d'application elle est elle
est réside de la combinaison des hommes
politiques et des femmes politiques de
droite et de gauche là c'est dû en même
temps puisque le rip a été créé sous
Nicolas Sarkozy et codifier dans ce
modalités concrètes sous François
Hollande donc il y a une combinaison des
deux types de majorité politiques pour
aboutir à la procédure kafkaïenne que
l'on connaît aujourd'hui et que en
réalité personne ne souhaite modifier
j'ai un collègue tout le monde connaît
ici qui s'appelle Benjamin Morel qui a
proposé un RIB sur le RIB il faudrait en
effet
faciliter cette procédure mais je crois
que ce sera pas pour demain
ça donne ce sentiment effectivement à
l'article de Benjamin dit l'aider
effectivement on appelait à ce RIB sur
le rip mais on voit qu'il y a un souci
puisque ça donne le sentiment la
séquence qu'on vient de voir que ça a
été conçu pour qu'on s'en servir jamais
pour que ça ne marche pas or il y a bien
un problème qui est que aux yeux de
l'option public le système démocratique
un peu bloqué qui ne donne pas assez de
respiration démocratique qu'une vraie
demande de la part des citoyens de
davantage dire leurs mots sur des grands
choix de politique publique sur des
grandes décisions on voit que le
référendum est un outil qui est très
très soutenu dans le pion publique il y
a près de 70 75% des personnes qu'on
interroge nous dans nos enquêtes aussi
il faut davantage de référendum par
contre on voit que là il y a vraiment un
souci puisque maintenant forcée de
constater que je crois qu'il y a eu cinq
demandes de RIP et pour le moment il y
en a eu qu'une seule qui a été validée
par le Conseil constitutionnel sera
Aéroport de Paris et encore avec
beaucoup de difficultés à ré tout juste
un million de signatures donc il y a un
problème qui est que notre démocratie ne
va pas si bien que ça il y a une
aspiration profonde dans l'opinion à la
prise de parole en direct des citoyens
et des citoyens et il manque l'outil
pour le moment pour le pour le faire
donc il y a un beau chantier de ce point
de vue là
institutionnel et politique Laurent
Berger dit ce matin que la lutte contre
le texte n'est pas fini le prochain
espoir des opposants c'est cette
proposition de loi de l'iode qui serait
examinée lui joint pour abroger il faut
dire les choses de manière objective
c'est très bien de donner des espoirs
mais les espoirs qui sont
systématiquement déçus peuvent avoir des
effets négatifs cette proposition de loi
va être examinée par l'Assemblée
nationale le 8 juin il est probable que
l'Assemblée nationale la vote et sur le
plan symbolique ce serait très important
absolument non la proposition de loi
pour que la proposition des républicains
pour qu'elle soit votée à l'Assemblée
pour vous peut-être en tout cas il faut
une majorité relative et cette majorité
relative elle peut être obtenue mais
la proposition de loi ne deviendra loi
que si elle est ensuite votée par le
Sénat et nous sommes ici à Public Sénat
et Bruno Retailleau qui était sur votre
plateau à l'instant je ne crois pas
qu'il souhaitera que soit abrogé la loi
qui a porté à 64 ans là je n'ai pas la
retraite donc il est assez improbable
que le Sénat accepte de revenir à 62 ans
donc cette proposition de loi encore
même si elle passe la barrière de
l'Assemblée nationale ne passera pas à
celle du Sénat il y a disons un vote
symbolique qui sera fait politiquement
ce sera très fort mais juridiquement je
ne pense pas que la loi sur la réforme à
64 ans sera abrogée
et par ailleurs même si à l'Assemblée il
faut une majorité relative on voit que
l'équation politique devient extrêmement
compliqué parce qu'on s'imagine bien que
du côté des républicains si on joue un
ses voix à cette idée ça coupera cours
un petit peu à l'idée éventuellement ou
d'une alliance d'un contrat de
gouvernement ou voilà donc on voit que
les dimensions politiques va être
également très importante à l'Assemblée
nationale il y a également une autre
idée qui est mise qui est l'idée selon
laquelle on pourrait faire comme au
moment du CPE c'était promulgué et puis
finalement c'est pas c'est pas appliqué
et je crois pas que ça soit tellement
souhaitable dans un système politique de
dire qu'au fond à un moment donné bien
les lois ne sont pas suivi des faits
elles sont promulguées mais au fond
elles ne sont pas appliquées je suis pas
sûr que ça soit très souhaitable dans
l'état de l'opinion par rapport au
fonctionnement démocratique elle a aussi
ça ferait passer un message qu'un
message assez confus on ne sait plus
très très bien au fond l'état
du dossier il y a un moment donné où
quand même il faut que les Françaises et
les Français sont un peu au clair et
puis se projeter à un an deux ans en
sachant exactement à quel moment ils
vont partir en retraite qu'est-ce qui
les attend il faut que les
fonctionnaires puissent savoir s'il peut
faire de la cessation progressive
d'activité se maintient en activité
jusqu'à 70 ans
l'idée qu'il aura cette fameuse close de
revoyure c'est-à-dire transformant les
élections de 2027 comme aussi un grand
moment démocratique revenant sur cette
question sauf qu'on a aussi entendu ça à
l'heure de la précédente réforme des
retraites la réforme Fillon avec des
oppositions qui disait mais quand on
arrive au pouvoir on reviendra dessus
personne n'est revenu sur la sur la
réforme des retraites est-ce que c'est
crédible que les oppositions reviennent
sur cette réforme là et bien ce serait
de d'essayer de faire en sorte qu'elle
devienne crédibles voilà c'est vrai
qu'on a quand même la mémoire courte
collectivement et les événements du jour
peuvent s'effacer très rapidement de nos
mémoire est-ce que du coup Bruno
l'opinion politique a défaut d'approuver
cette réforme elle est en train de se
résigner à son application et à son
entrée en vigueur un peu c'est la
tendance des dernières enquête d'opinion
qui qui au fond disent il y a toujours
pas d'adhésion à cette idée de
travailler plus longtemps mais il y a
aussi l'idée que finalement Emmanuel
Macron est parvenu à ses fins on voit
que le soutien aux mobilisation est
aussi un petit peu en retrait
le 1er mai est une très grande
démonstration de force des syndicats
très réussi bien évidemment une forte
capacité à nouveau à mobiliser il y aura
sans doute du monde à nouveau dans les
rues le 6 juin
néanmoins votre progressivement dans
l'opinion publique l'idée est en train
de de passer que finalement Emmanuel
Macron est arrivé à faire passer sa
réforme alors vous parliez du premier
mai il y avait effectivement beaucoup de
monde dans les rues mais il y a aussi
des violences qui ont émaillées
plusieurs cortèges et du coup le
gouvernement remet sur la table Audrey
l'idée d'une loi anti-casseurs
ce sont les modérés Dupont-Moretti dans
une interview hier c'est officielle il
travaille sur le sujet avec son
homologue de l'Intérieur Gérald de
Darmanin ils vont se voir demain l'idée
d'abord c'est de sanctionner plus
fermement les casseurs écoutez
il y a des manifestants qui manifestent
et cette
liberté que la Constitution leur
reconnaît puis elle est casseurs et cela
il faut pas leur faire de cadeau parce
qu'ils viennent là pour détruire pour
démolir pour casser du flic pour tuer
sur ce sujet le garde des sceaux demande
aussi une réponse plus ferme quand les
casseurs s'en prennent aux forces de
l'ordre dans ce projet de loi il
pourrait y avoir aussi l'interdiction
pour les manifestants condamnés pour
violence de participer à des
rassemblements pour Gérald de Darmanin
cela se fera à la manière des hooligans
interdit de stade on interdit au
casseurs de venir en manifestation pour
l'instant d'après Christophe Béchu le
ministre de la transition écologique qui
était sur votre plateau hier Oriane nous
n'avons pas l'arsenal législatif pour le
faire d'où l'idée de ce projet de loi
sauf que c'est pas la première fois
Audrey qu'on tente de faire un texte sur
ce sujet non en 2019 Bruno Retailleau le
président du groupe LR au Sénat avait
déjà fait une première tentative avec un
texte visant à interdire des personnes
représentant une menace d'une
particulière gravité de manifester
pendant un mois le texte avait été
adopté par le Parlement avant d'être
partiellement censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel au motif qu'il constitue
une atteinte au droit d'expression
collective des idées et des opinions
garanties par l'article 11 de la
Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme et du
Citoyen alors le principal intéressé
Bruno Retailleau était justement sur
votre plateau Oriane il y a quelques
minutes il a redescendu son texte il
estime qu'à l'époque le gouvernement
l'avait dénaturé avec dénaturé sa
mouture et ça avait expliqué la raison
de la censure on l'écoute
moi j'avais prévu des conditions très
resserrées par exemple que le préfet
pouvant interdire simplement pour la
durée d'une manifestation aux abords et
dans la manifestation et sous
l'impulsion de Monsieur Castaner les
députés avaient voté quelque chose de
beaucoup plus large surtout le
territoire national qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire première proposition reprend le
texte que j'avais proposé équilibré et
je pense qu'il passera les mailles du
Conseil constitutionnel pour appliquer
ce gonfler vous allez reprendre mon
texte vous appelez le ministre de le
ministre de l'Intérieur a finalement
travaillé avec une erreur c'est une
erreur de gouvernement ils ont dénaturé
mon texte ils se sont fait censurer
est-ce que le gouvernement s'il reprend
le texte de Bruno Retailleau peut passer
les mailles du Conseil constitutionnel
je ne sais pas ça dépendra la
formulation je crois en tout état de
cause qu'ici vraiment le sujet est un
peu déplacé en réalité on a déjà
beaucoup beaucoup de doigts en matière
sécurité vous l'avez rappelé il y a la
loi noix de 2019 qui a déjà été adopté
pour prévenir les violences dans les
manifestations on a un arsenal
sécuritaire qui est très complet et par
ailleurs depuis à peu près un mois il
est possible d'utiliser des drones pour
surveiller les manifestations c'est ce
qui a été fait à Paris et on nous avait
dit les drones sont nécessaires pour
éviter les violences il y a eu trois
drones qui ont survolé les
manifestations du 1er mai à Paris et
d'autres drones dans d'autres ça n'a pas
empêché les les violences qui ont été
commises par conséquent il faut acter le
fait c'est ce qu'on ne voit pas Bruno
Retailleau que des mesures législatives
sécuritaires n'empêcheront pas jamais
que des violences soient commises à
l'égard de force de l'Europe
même si on les durcit ce n'est pas comme
ça qu'on va éviter les viols que les
violences soient commises à l'égard des
forces de l'ordre ça fait 20 ans pour
les interdictions de stade où on empêche
certains supporters fichés de se rendre
au stade pour vous c'est pas possible on
va dans un stade on va dans un lieu
public qui est fermé c'est pas comme
marché sur la voie publique et on peut
pas empêcher quelqu'un de déambuler sur
la voie publique et de manifester on
peut pas présumer qu'une personne va
avoir un comportement violent au cours
de telles manifestations c'est
impossible ou alors on change de régime
donc pour vous aucune loi ne pour
empêcher les Black Blocs
législatif le sujet est politique et
social
oui on voit qu'effectivement sans aucun
doute le Conseil constitutionnel devrait
être fidèle à sa première doctrine de
2019 effectivement quand il avait
partiellement censuré le projet de loi
du du gouvernement
du point de vue effectivement de la la
question politique et de la gestion de
l'opiant public on voit que le
gouvernement est sur une corde raide en
fait c'est pas c'est pas facile d'un
côté il y a des forces de l'ordre qui
ont été terriblement sollicitées depuis
plusieurs mois il y a une option
publique qui supporte sans doute de
moins en moins de voir des images de
violence on a vu cette image
spectaculaire il est encore quelques
heures d'un policier dans le dans
l'uniforme prenez feu donc voilà il y a
il y a quand même des réactions
c'est ça un peu la difficulté de gérer à
la fois la demande d'ordre qui existe
dans le pays nous dans les enquêtes du
cevipov on demande aux françaises et aux
Français ce que vous pensez ce dont le
pays a besoin c'est d'une bonne dose
d'autorité on voit que cette opinion est
assez partagée quand même dans le pays
donc il y a une demande de spoiler de
gérer la situation
et le gouvernement est sur une corde
effectivement très très difficile parce
que s'il ne fait rien qui n'en vaut
aucun message à l'opinion s'installe
l'idée progressivement qu'effectivement
il y a besoin d'une bonne dose
d'autorité et que ce gouvernement n'y
arrive pas ce qui est problématique si
le gouvernement va dans un sens qui est
effectivement
à nouveau de d'accroître l'arsenal
législative on voit qu'il va être
censuré par le Conseil constitutionnel
et de ce point de vue là c'est pas
souhaitable non plus pas par le
gouvernement donc très très difficile
donc c'est effectivement à la fois une
gestion de l'option public c'est-à-dire
comment passer le message qu'il y a
quelque chose qui est fait pour empêcher
que ces images ne reviennent
régulièrement sur nos écrans difficile
il y a une gestion également qui est une
gestion du modèle français du maintien
de l'ordre il y a beaucoup de réflexions
qui ont été conduites le nouveau préfet
de police avait semble-t-il été pas mal
couronné de succès dans un dans un dans
un premier temps donc il y a sans doute
à ce que les parlementaires
se saisissent de cette question le
modèle français de maintien de l'ordre
pourquoi est-il régulièrement mis en
difficulté par des se développe comment
on pourrait améliorer la situation c'est
plutôt de ça dont il faut parler
effectivement que de d'aller vers une
impasse juridique on va parler du
maintien de l'homme mais un mot le
gouvernement réfléchit notamment à la
création d'un délit de construction de
barricades pour vous c'est pas tenable
pour le casser c'est vraiment pas le
sujet d'autant plus qu'il va y avoir une
autre manifestation le 6 juin puis après
il y aura les vacances donc c'est
vraiment pas très urgent c'est pas
urgent et encore une fois j'y insiste on
ne résoudra pas ces difficultés réelles
de gestion de l'ordre par la loi je
rappelle je voudrais juste insister sur
ce point qu'il y a eu trois drones qui
ont survolé la manifestation du 1er mai
et ces trois drones ont été justifiés
par le préfet de police par la nécessité
de prévenir les débordements violents
trois c'était la première fois que des
drones survolaient une manifestation
traditionnelle du premier ça n'a pas
empêché ses débordements il faut revoir
la stratégie du maintien de l'ordre non
il faut revoir les politiques sociales
pour qu'il n'y ait pas de débordement
pendant les manifestations
politiques et oui
une différence entre les manifestants
qui viennent manifester pacifiquement
et les casseurs qui viennent alors le
gouvernement dit viennent pour tuer du
flic oui c'est ce que dit le
gouvernement
ce type de difficulté et il y a des
contestations je suis même manifestant
régulier je manifeste tranquillement
enfin je pense en certifié mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a des débordements il faut
les réprimer quand ils quand ils
existent et il faut aussi surtout les
prévenir il faut essayer de les prévenir
comme l'a dit Bruno par une politique de
gestion de l'ordre adapté au début des
manifestations en janvier février il y a
eu aucun débordement ils se sont accrus
à compter de la mise en œuvre du 49.3
donc il n'y a pas que la loi il n'y a
pas que la répression qui permet
d'évider les d'éviter les débordements
il y a des politiques sociales une
manière de gérer l'ordre public qui peut
parvenir avec beaucoup plus de résultats
au même objectif un dernier mot
rapidement Bruno cotress est-ce que
cette loi alors on a entendu Eric du
pourrais-tu dire qu'il est réfléchit
mais dire en même temps qu'il faut
prendre le temps alors qu'on a
l'impression que Gérald Darmanin lui met
plus la pression pour que cette loi
arrive rapidement ça va pouvoir se faire
entre le garde des sols ministres à
l'intérieur c'est toujours un dialogue
intéressant et parfois compliqué entre
lise l'intérieur de la justice
évidemment d'autant qu'ils n'ont pas du
tout les mêmes perspectives ou les mêmes
agendas politiques personnels
Eric Dupond-Moretti n'a pas l'ambition
un jour de candidater à de très très
hautes fonctions
ministre l'intérieur davantage de
stratégie politique on voit que Gérald
Darmanin inscrit son parcours politique
un peu dans le siège de Nicolas Sarkozy
dont il est un peu c'est un peu son
mentor et c'est vrai que quelque chose
marqué profondément le parcours de
Nicolas Sarkozy vers l'Elysée qui était
son passage place Beauvau
puisque c'est à la Une de certains de
vos quotidiens régionaux
[Musique]
et Audrey au quotidien revienne ce matin
sur le rejet de cette deuxième demande
de référendum d'initiative partagée sur
les retraites oui regardez les Dernières
Nouvelles d'Alsace l'Alsace la Voix du
Nord reviennent sur cette info qui est
tombée hier en fin de journée bon faut
chercher un peu c'est pas en grand en
une le Conseil constitutionnel estime
donc que la deuxième demande de RIP et
non conforme il est donc enterré alors
les conditions du Rip le rendent en fait
presque impraticable juste le début juge
le député François Ruffin qui était
interviewé dans les pages intérieures de
la Voix du Nord désormais la bataille
continue à l'Assemblée nationale vous
l'avez dit l'actualité c'est aussi des
préoccupations en matière
d'environnement Christophe Béchu le
ministre de la transition écologique
était interviewée par Corse-Matin et
interview par Corse-Matin il est
notamment question de quota dans les
sites touristiques sur fréquentés vous
connaissez encore Soriane il y en a un
certain nombre faut-il généraliser les
réservations c'est ce qui est
expérimenté pardon actuellement dans les
calanques marseillaises pourquoi pas
répond le ministre et puis sur le thème
de l'environnement aussi la Charente
Libre la grâce aux débroussaillement
pour éviter de nourrir le feu 53
communes de Charente peut-être 23 de
plus vont devoir faire l'obligation de
nettoyer autour des applications des
habitations pardon une obligation qui
fâche car la tâche peut s'avérer
gigantesque il faut si vous habitez à
200 mètres d'une forêt débroussaillée à
50 mètres autour de votre maison même
chez votre voisin alors le code le
l'autorise mais le Code civil l'interdit
donc vous voyez quelques contradictions
et puis je terminer rapidement avec une
histoire hors du commun je l'attendais
au procès d'une mamie ditleuse oui
tenez-vous bien 70 ans en fauteuil
roulant elle avait trop transformé son
appartement en pointe d'île pour
satisfaire sa fille qui était dépendante
de la drogue héroïne cocaïne ont trouvé
de tout chez celles qui étaient
surnommée l'ancienne la vieille alors la
mamie avait des valeurs elle avait
décidé de nous vendre comme majeur pas
question de faire crédit et pas de vente
après 21h pour pouvoir se reposer mais
bon je rappelle que c'est illégal de
faire tout ça elle a été condamnée à
deux ans de prison avec sursis or Iane
merci Audrey pour cette histoire merci
beaucoup Paul Cassia d'avoir été avec
nous merci Bruno co tresse merci à tous
de nous avoir suivi si vous voulez voir
au revoir cette émission vous pouvez la
retrouver sur notre nouvelle plateforme
public sénat.fr prochain rendez-vous 18h
Thomas Hugues sens public on se retrouve
demain très bonne journée
[Musique]